most labour party members are not
anti-semitic what will you do to dispel
the misconception amongst voters
anti-semitism is rife in the party well
deal with it i suppose it's the obvious
answer to that i mean i felt very
strongly about this because i represent
a town
where my working-class labour party
members
have gone and fought racism and fought
off the far right
over and over again for decades we saw
tommy robinson off
last year in the european elections and
if he tries to come back to wigan we'll
see him off again
and they were knocking on doors in this
election being told that they were
racist
when because we'd had a collective
failure of leadership at the top of the
party
four years where we'd allowed
high-profile cases of anti-semitism
to go undealt with and unaddressed and
by doing so
we've given a green light to
anti-semites everywhere that they had a
home in labour
now look i spoke up about this i spoke
up about it when i was in the shadow
cabinet it's the only time i broke
collective responsibility
and i spoke up on every occasion in the
three years
after that and the reason that i did
that is because i am half indian
and i know what racism feels like and i
know that it cannot be your battle alone
to fight it
there is no such thing as being not
racist there is either being a racist or
there is being
an anti-racist it requires you to take
an active stance
and to go out and challenge and fight
for better that is what i did there is a
serious question of judgment here and i
would just say this to kier
is that i believe that you are sincere
about this but if we do not acknowledge
how badly the shadow cabinet as a whole
got this wrong
we will not earn the trust of the jewish
community and those people that you talk
about
who i want to see back in the party will
never look to us again
lisa you were in a shadow cabinet when
this issue came up as well
[Applause]
and then i left and i didn't return and
i continued to speak out for three years
and you know the shadow cabinet was
offered site of the
submission to the equality and human
rights commission
which was investigating labor for
institutional racism
and apparently not a single person took
up the offer
of seeing the party's position absolute
nonsense
uh we've talked to be honest about
whether you've got hear me out about
what actually happened
i don't break shadow cabinet should be
confidential and i don't break the
confidences
it was tom watson and i that were asking
for that submission and we're offered it
so this is complete nonsense that was
what we were trying to do
i argued we should change the definition
to the international definition i
anchored it for months in the shadow
cabinet and in the end we did it
i argued that we should have automatic
ex expulsion
of clear cases and in the end after
those arguments we did it so we made it
you're talking
about not wanting to break shadow
cabinet responsibility do you remember
rebecca lombally speaking out
well enchanted cabinet
i think the last thing our members our
movement and our country wants
is us all trying to take lumps out of
each other about who did what
the test for us is how would we deal
with this as leader of the labour party
and i would take a leadership role of
this people i wanted to know
what happened when it came to comes to
anti-semitism that is fair isn't it
people want to know the truth
massive rows in the shadow cabinet we
were absolutely on it and we were making
massive arguments i was saying over
again
once that equality and human rights
commission is looking at us don't close
the books give them
access to all of our did rebecca on
bailey speak out at shadow cabinet
look uh rebecca um
didn't speak out in the same way as i
did in my view but i really really don't
think
and i don't think it's fair and it's
right for us to just try to score points
now off each other in relation to this i
want to bring you in
i want to i want to bring in rebecca at
this point in four weeks time
the test for us is how are we going to
deal with it as a leader
talk now to rebecca and bailey it's only
fair to bring in rebecca on bailly
at that point what what is your
recollection elections of what happened
in the shadow cabinet i'm not pointing
fingers or making a note of the exact
dates and times that particular
individuals spoke at shadow cabinet he
knows that i spoke at shadow cabinet a
number of times about this
i was often the shadow cabinet member
that did the media
to try and explain what was happening
and expressed my concern
many many times about how we weren't
tackling this in the way that i thought
we should
well the time doesn't seem to be what he
has retrospective criticism
of each other has gone we are in a
crisis and i know that it's been
soul-destroying for many of our members
because we're not an anti-semitic or a
racist
party but many of our members went out
in that general election and they
knocked on the doors of jewish voters
who didn't trust us and they were
frightened of the labour party and we
have to accept
that that has happened and we've got to
rebuild that trust and that's why we
need to have an independent process for
complaints not just for anti-semitism
for all forms of discrimination within
the party we've got to adopt any
recommendations that the ehrc
put forward in the coming months and we
need to auto expo
have an auto expulsion process for
clear-cut cases of anti-semitism and
racism within our
party okay thank you very much